Taylor Swift once gave you a compliment
there was a rift that you came up with
and she said she walked right up to you
and said oh my God that is like such a
great riff right I was doing I think
like a radio show or something yeah and
we were just passing by and she was like
oh my God nice to see you like better
now is [__] amazing better now is so
insane that Jek you
so thank you so much and I was like what
that's [__] crazy you're a great
[__] song thank you so very much like
that makes you feel good right yeah well
I mean it's just like you know there's
so many beautiful um artists in the
world and for uh another artist um to
acknowledge that is a really really
really bitching thing it's a really
special thing so I I think that that was
a really cool moment and it it was very
inspiring what do you make of what's
going going on with her right now it
seems like she just got to some weird
level of Fame and success where the the
tour she was on just made $4 billion and
then her movie just did like a hundred
million at the box office in a week like
what the [__] it's [__] so cool it's
so cool and um it's
just how how does she handle that and I
recently got to to hang out with and and
she is
genuinely one of the most like kind and
considerate and a [__] hell of a
songwriter holy [__] amazing absolutely
amazing Travis Kelce her now new
boyfriend you played him in beer pong
yes sir I think you played him and
Patrick Mahomes and beer Pang you
lost and the the penalty was don't say
that so loud don't say that so loud well
Hey listen it's the way it is someone's
going to hear someone's going to hear
you and what was the penalty what was
the penalty of losing uh beer pun to
Travis Kelce and Patrick Mahomes I had
to get to Kansas City Chiefs uh Patrick
Mahomes and Travis Kelce tattoo yeah
where is that tattoo where is it on your
body well hidden on my ass well hidden
sorry no I don't mean that they're very
sweet guys talented players
um it's on my
arm it is somewhat embarrassing that you
lost to them in beer pong like no it's
not it is they're athletes they're
athletes but you're a legendary Beer
Drinker uh you know what I mean you you
drink a lot of alcohol I mean you what
is this you became a dad and now your
your beer pong is diminishing is that
happening too I mean what's going I will
say I will say that it did affect my
beer pong skills becoming a father I
think it does automatically take um two
points off um but I will say this and I
told I told Taylor tell him I said those
elbows were
crazy and um you can't have your elbows
crossing over the table so I'd like a
rematch I'd like to say here on the
Howard Stern Show I'd like to say Travis
Kelsey Patrick
Mahomes I am so
ready